you talk about being driven which is
awesome and i see that and i also see
the not being satisfied which is great
i've seen a lot of driven people talk
about that which
gets them higher but is there pressure
that you place on yourself not just with
the the youtube following and the vine
following but also because
you want to do more films like along the
roadside and and tv and things like that
is there a pressure you feel from
yourself to do what to what to to keep
getting more roles to keep
because it's an engine that you've got
to keep well yeah i mean there's there's
always
there's always pressure because a it's
like people don't know what it's like to
try to
juggle a vine account and a youtube
account which is already extremely time
time consuming then thinking about how
to keep growing your instagram because
you have to post certain times a day and
suppose pull certain things to get more
followers and then on top of that oh
wait i have this audition and it read
lines for but wait i have to shoot a
vine i have to shoot a youtube video oh
wait but i have more auditions so it it
is very
taxing
you know um
it takes a lot out of you and it is
there's a level of pressure and then
it's like you know as an actor you know
you're not getting younger so you want
to get more roles faster and it's like
yeah there's a lot of pressure
and then how do you deal with it how do
you compartmentalize it
um it's always a work in progress trying
to compartmentalize it you know it's
it's i don't have it down i don't have
it perfect
but i just continue to build my social
networks online and continue to hit
auditions when my my managers or my
agent sends me auditions i go into beast
mode and i'm focused and i go in there
and i know my lines i go early and i'm
just ready to perform and i have a great
time auditioning um
but you know i take it day by day trying
to juggle all this because it's like
it's
the the internet youtube and vine it's
still kind of like the wild west you
know it's still undefined even though
youtube's been around for a while
vines newer vine is like the wild west
right now and like social media is
getting into the the traditional
hollywood world everything's all mixing
up and everything is still new so i'm
still even at this point i'm still
learning
do you ever have days where you're not
in beast mode well of course
of course it's it's hard as because the
difference is when you're when you're a
person like me who's big on social media
you don't work a nine to five it's all
on you to push yourself there's no boss
saying you need to be at work at 8 a.m
unless i have a call time that's
different but on a day to day when i'm
trying to juggle youtube and vine and
instagram and auditions and it's just me
it takes a lot of drive to get yourself
up every day and follow a routine
without having someone push you
so that's a big challenge sometimes
especially when you
you know if you're living comfortably
and you don't need to get up
it can be a little bit of a challenge so
unless you have interviews